Christian it's great to have you here at
the London Film comic-con and what the
kind of debut had so far and it's been
if I could swear I would say laughing
mantle that's been really crazy a lot of
people here today
now something else that has been effing
mental it was the last days ago it's
right sweetie please season 3 episode 9
the red wedding have you seen it what
did you think of it I have seen
obviously I knew it was coming and I
think the last time I was talking I
couldn't I couldn't talk about it but
it's got exactly the reaction I imagined
really so everyone's freaking out yeah
everyone's really shocked it's one of
those things even if you've read the
books or you're in the car says that
you've know the scripts that's what it's
still oh my god I can't believe they're
doing that yeah I heard a reaction a lot
of people saying the knew it was coming
but they didn't want it to happen
they're kind of willing it not to happen
please don't do it but they did it yeah
you killed some extra people shoulda
killed his wife last time we spoke we
were talking about what it awesome king
that Hodor would make and a lot of
people are they're alike in that they
live in Hodor for this Arroyo do a
wondering what would King Hodor do I
would kill anyone who's not dead no I
think
I think he would a drill with a fair
hands strong but fair hand and this is
obviously presuming he got a Korean buck
yeah I don't think it would be much of a
king as he is but yeah I think you'd be
a fair king do you think he'd take a
queen or who do you think it'd take as
Queen every turn no idea I think it
would probably ask you to come back I
think I think holder would have a better
question aren't you I like that Perry
yeah this junk as well so I think she'd
probably come back no she'll be back
with the first boat I think that a great
line that she has after not seeing it so
they're in the God Squad but she knows
what she knows the speed for now if you
could give her some advice first season
four and future seasons what would you
say to him
find the smaller child dump Brown into
the snow and beware of White Walkers
yeah beware of White Walkers talking
about another W that's been going on
this season there's been a lot of
walking going on we talked a bit about
it long time how how really which did
you enjoy that thing that was probably
my favorite thing so far of my adoring
talk about last time I think it's a new
dimension the whole relationship I hope
and they'll explore more of that and
season four through the books really
probably well I don't know for sure but
that'll be fun fun to be had if you
think about the characters you've got in
the show so far and maybe wants to come
who do you think will be there in the
best around obviously we don't know
because Jojo and haven't finished the
books yet I would imagine Cersei and
Tyrion will still be there I'm sure a
virus will still be there the whole
thing here will still be there
probably New Starts left Brown will turn
into the captain those quarters those
boaters yeah I think Alana shoes what I
lost everybody I would say they're
sticky
[ __ ] curse their their eyes I'm
wondering if before you get the scripts
in and maybe the guys you haven't read
the books and said do you ever take bets
about who's gonna die this season no
that's not very nice you can say that to
your cast mates back to the job so my
god I said do you have a tape I'm taking
over
you know the guys in we get scripts and
you know the guys we not read books or
today do you ever have bets about who's
gonna die this season
oh so he's having bets behind my back
yeah with that he was gone yeah back to
me we were short we do not take baths on
each other's damn that's what happens we
can't have too much that go no no no
have you could bring anybody back after
all many people who've fallen by the
wayside I'll go with Rowan's hewed you
bring back who do you bring back to life
that's an interesting question my knee
jerk reaction would be say Ned
because I think you know such a good
character he was so short-lived you know
I think he deserves a bit more really
good character yeah I'm gonna bring that
back I think I'll be the popular choice
as well yeah finally what are you most
looking forward to in season 4 what we
do like to have a friend Jones oh my god
and the word working working and snow
okay insert it working and snow perfect
thank you very much
you